[Applause]
[Music]
hello tim hello
where do you think you are uh
somewhere uh
comfortable wrong you are dead
good how do you think you died i was
assassinated
for uh being a good person
are you sad you are dead no
i don't recall being sad before i was
born
do you want to create a eulogy to be
remembered by
uh it would probably be a good idea
please answer the following questions to
generate your eulogy
did you live a good life yeah for the
most part
i was able to uh produce two beautiful
children and i was married to a
beautiful wonderful person
made some good friends had a lot of
laughs got to play some music
what do you regret the most in your life
you know i regret if uh i could have
been kinder
i could have been more patient i could
have been more empathetic towards other
people
what was the biggest achievement in your
career
i think that i've been able to
consistently
makes stuff on my own terms that enough
people
enjoy to give me the opportunity to keep
doing it
what was your most special morning has
to be the
morning uh my daughter was born that
just said what a six a.m
and uh spending that morning with her
was very
very special what simple pleasure did
you enjoy the most in your life
peanut m m's bags and bags
who do you most look forward to seeing
now that you're moving on from your life
uh my old friend phil from uh from high
school
we uh we're pals and he passed away way
too soon
what will you miss most about your
family you know the affection they show
me
what recent work were you most proud of
the
most recent work i'm proud of is my
record fear of death it's
a speaking of it's a very fully realized
version of my musical ambitions
and i'm proud of it because it features
so many
talented people playing beautiful music
on it what is a famous quote that you
would associate with your life
i don't know how famous it is it's a
quote i think about a lot which is
uh work begets inspiration and that's
from paul mccartney
to me it means that you don't just sit
around and think of ideas
like they're just going to pop in there
you do you work you
you start with something and by doing
that you become inspired by what you end
up really doing
what one word would you use to describe
your childhood
uh rambunctious i probably would have
been medicated if i had
grown up in the 90s or 2000s i
was quite hyperactive you know that
usually rep was expressed itself in
being a clown or being goofy
what is one word you would use to
describe yourself now
multifaceted what do you want to be
remembered for
a diverse career in the entertainment
industry
thank you tim you may now proceed to the
eulogy
thank you
[Music]
hmm
hi everybody i'd uh
i'd like to begin by thanking everyone
for coming to celebrate the
the decent and pretty good tim heidecker
he's all right
tim was the most multi-faceted person
i've ever known
when you remember tim heidecker you
remember some of his most standout
moments like the birth of his daughter
or
the world premiere of billion dollar
movie at the sundance film festival
where many people
stayed tim loved the simple life he
loved
dipping his big old hands into a giant
party sized bag of peanut m
ms and shoving it in his mouth and then
dipping that hand
back in that party bag and shoving it
again and doing that over and over and
over again
until the party bag was fully empty he
loved spending time with his family
and he loved the affection they showed
him
he wasn't as interested in showing them
affection he had too much on his plate
tim was born on february 3rd 1976 in a
snowstorm beautiful blizzard
in allentown pennsylvania his childhood
was rambunctious he was a
wild child doing really innovative
sketches for five-year-olds at the time
really groundbreaking stuff
as an adult he had a remarkable career
from doing those puppet shows in his
basement to tim and eric awesome show
bedtime stories
moon base eight on show time and
eventually acting in films such as
bridesmaids and
us which he won several awards for
we know he was proud to say that he made
stuff on his
own terms and he was so excited to share
his recent work fear of death the lp
that won the album of the year
and many grammys on top of that
four star record yeah he never expressed
it but
he knew that he could have been more
patient
he could have been more kind he could
have been more empathetic
to other people and i know if he's up
there
he's full of regrets i'll remember him
as a diverse entertainer
he was acting he was doing comedy he did
music
did a podcast i mean who does all that
it pains me to lose tim to the great
beyond but i know he's spending time
with his buddy
phil who died too soon his grandma and
grandpa
and his other grandma and his other
grandpa
and all four members of the beatles
in closing i'd like to share a quote
from paul mccartney work begets
inspiration
go out and try and just do something get
started
the good idea is they start churning
once you put the work in
it is in that spirit that i would like
to bid a fond farewell to the one and
only the great
tim heidecker let's hear it for him
and now
i'm gonna get to work
hmm
not too bad
okay see you later
you